[ Knock on door ]
-Come in.
-Hi, Lin.
-Oh, hey, Jimmy.
I'm so excited to be
on the show tonight.
Isn't this great?
-Yeah, it is great.
It's, uh...
It's great.
-You okay, bud?
You seem pretty down.
-Well, just I was walking
to work today.
I walked through
the theater district,
and just made me miss Broadway.
-Jimmy, didn't you hear?
Broadway's coming back.
-Broadway's coming back?
-Yeah, Broadway's coming back
in September!
-This is so amazing.
Man, I miss going to see a play.
-And I miss playing.
[ Dramatic music plays ]
♪ Broadway, oh, Broadway ♪
♪ You're finally coming back ♪
♪ I miss drinking wine
out of sippy cups ♪
♪ And a $20 snack ♪
♪ A night at the theater ♪
♪ My favorite kind of date ♪
♪ I even miss the people
who always show up late ♪
-Hi. I'm sorry.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Is this row H?
No, I'm in I.
-♪ I miss Henry's wives
in "Six" ♪
-♪ Ex-wives ♪
-♪ Think of
all of that alimony ♪
♪ I miss that brooding phantom ♪
-♪ The only masked singer
with a Tony ♪
♪ I miss the ladies
of "Chicago" ♪
-♪ Can these legs
kick even higher? ♪
-♪ I miss that anxious
Evan Hansen ♪
-♪ Yes, I'm cute
but I'm a liar ♪
-♪ I miss going down
to Hadestown ♪
♪ For true love I'll go far ♪
-♪ I want to yell,
"Don't turn around" ♪
♪ To the guy with the guitar ♪
♪ On the West Side
there's a story ♪
♪ About the Jets and Sharks ♪
-♪ Where fighting
is just dancing ♪
-♪ And the lions
hit their marks ♪
-♪ It's been a year
of quarantine ♪
♪ It's time for company ♪
-Bobby, Bobby.
-♪ "Come From Away" taught me
all about hospitality ♪
-Sorry. Sorry.
♪ I miss Mormons
telling me hello ♪
-♪ Founding fathers dueling,
whoa ♪
♪ And dancers cancan-canning
through Paris ♪
-♪ I miss trying out
for "A Chorus Line" ♪
-♪ A whole new world
would be divine ♪
-♪ And feeling like
I'm defying gravity ♪
Sorry, I gained a few pounds
during quarantine.
-It's okay, Jimmy.
Keep going.
♪ But most of all,
I miss the crowds ♪
♪ The theater is packed,
they're cheering so loud ♪
♪ I just hope
we make it through ♪
-But, Lin, we have
a full audience now!
-♪ We do? ♪
-Yeah, man, we do.
-♪ We do ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ You say ♪
♪ It's been a full year ♪
♪ Since you've seen a live show
or a play ♪
-♪ You cry ♪
♪ In the terrible sourdough
starter you made to get by ♪
-♪ We've gone mad ♪
-♪ Remember we've been
in containment ♪
♪ For hundreds of days ♪
-♪ But it's not all bad ♪
-♪ In September,
for your entertainment ♪
♪ Broadway's back ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ And you'll be back ♪
♪ Soon you'll see ♪
♪ You'll remember
what it's like to be ♪
-♪ In Times Square for a show ♪
♪ Waving "hi"
to every drunk Elmo ♪
-♪ Take a break from your Zoom ♪
-♪ Your pet plants are safe
inside their rooms ♪
-♪ Won't you please
come with us? ♪
-♪ There is life beyond
your friends at Netflix ♪
♪ Hulu, Peacock, Disney+ ♪
-♪ Da da da da da ♪
♪ Da da da da da ya la ♪
♪ Da da da da da ♪
♪ Da da da da ♪
-Everybody!
-♪ Da da da da da ♪
♪ Da da da da da ya la ♪
♪ Da da da da da ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-My thanks to
Lin-Manuel Miranda,
Jimmy Smits, Olga Merediz.
"In the Heights"
is out this Thursday.
Thank you to Kristin Chenoweth,
Phylicia Rashad, Laura Benanti,
and Christopher Jackson!
We'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show"!
Come on back!
-♪ Da da da da da ♪
♪ Da da da da da ya la ♪
♪ Da da da da da ♪
-♪ Ohhh ♪
-Confetti!
Confetti!
Confetti means something!
When there's confetti,
there's a party.
Come on.
Thank you guys.
Amazing, amazing, amazing.
Broadway's back!
Thank you very much.
Love you guys.